Hello, I'm Berna Lidero with VOA 60 America.
US Secretary of State John Kerry expressed confidence Monday...
...that pro-government forces in Iraq would regain control...
...of the provincial capital of Ramadi from Islamic State fighters.
Speaking in South Korea a day after the militants claimed to have seized Ramadi,...
...Kerry said it was a "target of opportunity"...
...and that he was confident the situation there would be reversed in the days ahead.
Amtrak trains began rolling early Monday on the busy Northeast Corridor...
...that includes Boston, New York and Washington.
It was the first time in almost a week that service had been fully operational...
...since a deadly crash in Philadelphia that killed eight people...
...and injured more than 200 others.
Finally, police in Waco, Texas, said they were arresting 192 people Monday...
...in connection with a shootout at a sports bar over the weekend...
...that left nine dead and 18 injured.
The deadly gun battle occurred Sunday when at least five rival gangs...
...attacked each other outside the Twin Peaks Sports Bar and Grill.
That's all for today.
Thanks for watching.